chief Washington correspondent and Face
the Nation anchor John Dickerson is with
us John let's pick up on that they say
that President Putin will come to this
meeting very well-prepared ex-kgb
trained officer we've heard from the
Trump administration that they have no
formal agenda here does this give
President Putin an upper hand we've been
hearing that all morning well yeah the
administration has said they don't have
an agenda that's what they've said
publicly obviously privately they do
have an agenda North Korea Syria Ukraine
it's just a question of what the
president emphasizes certainly Vladimir
Putin has just more experience with
these kinds of exchanges and he's
essentially studied his whole life on
the other hand Donald Trump has been
through a few tough negotiations himself
so the question is just how the
conversation goes and whether it plays
to any of the men's underlying strengths
the key thing of course to watch is how
they both describe the meeting after
it's over
there is often quite a gulf between the
description of one country and another
and we'll see in that initial
description whether the meeting went
well or not as they both seek to
characterize it and in characterizing
that meeting is it there are many
lawmakers who are urging President Trump
to bring up the fact that Russia meddled
in the u.s. elections if Trump does not
do that what do you think the outcome
may be well the reason it's interesting
I mean for the for the meaning to go
quote-unquote well in the room you would
imagine the president not bringing that
up it's a sort it's a sore spot and
they've got lots of other difficult
things to discuss on the other hand the
president is quite limited by Congress
these days Congress the one bipartisan
act in Washington has been the sanctions
bill that passed out of the Senate and
so for the President to do some of the
things he might want to do to warm
relations with Russia in exchange for
getting Russia to help the u.s. in its
interests the president needs a little
leeway with Congress how would he get
that leeway by appearing tougher on
Russia because one of the things
Republicans and Democrats are worried
about is that the president is too soft
on Russia doesn't really recognize the
nature of the Russian threat so that's a
way in which the body language in the
room kind of works against the
president's interests at home
which out which he needs to improve in
order to get more free room to rein in
dealing with Russia but John Deere point
of the post meeting analysis so it's
possible they could leave and and the
president says yes we do I told them not
to meddle and and and Putin says we
didn't talk about that at all right and
you know there's part of this meeting
might be spent kind of tweaking the
language and saying look this is what
I'm going to say but don't take that too
literally because I'm playing to my
audience over here you've got a lot of
audiences there's a domestic audience
there's the audience in Syria the
audience in North Korea and so a little
bit of this meeting might be spent if it
happens on good terms sort of discussing
how they will read it out to the public
and and to make sure there's not a vast
difference as each characterizes what
happens not that any of this is staged
John know this this is all one big act
of serendipity and Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson as you know will be in the
room he of course knows Blatter Mir
Putin what does he bring to the table
well he's kind of a potential sort of
shoehorn into the relationship in other
words somebody who's worked with Putin
he understands the negotiating in Russia
certainly better than the President does
so we might be able to close a little
bit of the distance between the two men
on the other hand we will see some
complexity in the way the president
characterizes this meeting and the way
his Secretary of State characterizes it
in this administration so far we've seen
some distance
occasionally between the president's
softer rhetoric about Russia and the
rhetoric from his Secretary of State
Secretary of Defense and UN ambassador
so another usually it's just the
Americans and the country they're
meeting with where you look for distance
between the two readouts of an event in
this case how the president and I have
the Secretary of State characterized it
will also be something to watch Hooten
of course has 18 years experience in
government President Trump was a
businessman in his past
not in this formal stagecraft as these
sort of meetings go how do we know how
does president what do we know about how
President Trump prepares for these
meetings well there's been reporting
about how he's been given kind of bullet
point analysis in instruction on
the various different elements both of
Putin's character and also what the
objectives are in the conversation the
challenge is often not just sort of this
the first thing you say but the fifth or
sixth thing you say if you start going
down the road on the say Ukraine or or
on North Korea where where it can't
really be you can't really read up on
that you've got to kind of react in the
moment so if that'll be the most
fascinating thing is if they skip
lightly over the various issues
briefings in short bullet point
briefings might be enough if they really
dive into the specifics of something
like Syria then then that might be a
little bit more complicated but you know
the president's quite new to the stage
craft of this we've seen that throughout
his presidency but in the negotiations
he's had to deal with in real estate he
probably has more experience than a lot
of presidents dealing with people across
the table who who have very different
interests and who are tough customers
what does success look like Jon for the
president in terms of he can walk out
and we can look at this and say good job
president Trump well there's a success
in the room and and outside the room in
the room is a better relationship with
Putin outside the room is something the
president can declare as a win I'm not
sure exactly what that is until we see
it right John Dickerson thank you very
much for joining us from Washington DC
more to come for sure